hello everyone in this video we'll talk
about
high performance liquid chromatography
let's just analyze the name first high
performance
can tell us that this particular
chromatographic technique
have high resolution power second of all
liquid means here we use a mobile phase
which is
liquid so hplc chromatography
is just a chromatographic technique
which
has a very high resolution where the
mobile phase is liquid
and the mobile phase is passed through a
column
under very high pressure so this is the
overall principle
of high performance liquid
chromatography
so in this video we would understand why
this is
high performance and how exactly this
chromatographic technique works
what is the advantage and disadvantage
of these chromatography system
so just like any other chromatographic
technique
hplc also works on the same principle
so in a column chromatography which we
have seen earlier and if you don't know
about these videos the link would be
available in the i button
so the principle starts with
equilibration where the column is
equilibrated with buffer
followed by sample binding then
wash and ultimately illusion
so hplc has a similar
operation paradigm but here the
difference lies in the column and the
column is pretty special in hplc
the column is generally tightly packed
and these column materials are
small in size the particle size
varies from 2 to 50 micron
in average and in hplc
the pressure can
range from 50 to 350 bar
and this is pretty high pressure and
this
high pressure ensures the high
performance of this chromatographic
technique
now hplc columns could be of different
type
there could be affinity columns there
could be gel filtration columns
there could be ion exchange columns all
of these columns
are available in hplc so we can
understand
hplc to be a mode where all these column
materials are
same instead the column materials are
more sturdy in this case which can
withstand the high pressure
for example the gfc column would be
porous
but here the material would be way
sturdy than a conventional
gfc column now
all of these column would be
operating under very high pressure
and that is the key point about hplc
so let's just look at the column in bit
more details
so the hplc column includes silica
or hydroxyapatite media
or any kind of polystyrene
kind of beads which can withstand very
high
pressure now usage of smaller diameter
beads
generally results in improved separation
and this this reason is due to increased
surface area now the column pressure
increases as the bead diameter is
reduced so always there is a cut-off
limit
that how much the pressure can increase
so
we have a lower limit of these bead size
so the first step of this whole
procedure
is sample injection where sample
a very small amount of sample is
sufficient enough for
this technique so sample is injected
into the system
via a specialized sample injector
generally the sample injector
is connected with the auto sampler which
can load
multiple different samples in a semi
automated fashion in this machine
now let us look at the simplified
version of the inner working of
hplc and try to understand the
components
first of all there would be a pump which
can pump
a mobile phase in this system
now the pump is connected with a
de-gasser system
which can remove all the dissolved gas
in these fluids ultimately
there is a sample injector connected
with a rotatable
valve which can allow the injection of
the sample
under high pressure then the sample
along with the mobile phase
is passed through this column from this
column
it goes to a detector system in the
detector the sample annihilates are
actually detected the samples that are
separated are actually detected
and the data is displayed in a attached
computer
software and the rest amount of the
fluid is
either collected or collected in a waste
bottle
so let us understand the flow of liquid
in this setup so first of all
the mobile phase would be moving
through several tubings and these
tubings are
very sturdy such that it can with
withstand high pressure
now via degasser
it would pass through the pump while it
is passing through the dsr system
dissolved gases would be removed now the
pump
can able to move the liquid to the
sample injector
from the sample injector there would be
a mixing of the mobile phase
with the injected sample
and it would move through the column
and ultimately reach the detector while
in the detector
the samples would be detected so
there are two type of hplc columns
one is known as normal phase hplc
in the normal phase hplc what happens is
the stationary phase that means the
column material
is polar in nature often it has hydroxyl
groups
so hydroxyl group groups are
attached to the silica beads so when we
put sample in this column
they start separating and
the substances which are
polar would be left behind
what are substances which are nonpolar
or hydrophobic in nature they would be
eluted first and that is how the
separation works
now there is another kind of operation
regime
which is known as reverse phase hplc
in this reverse phase hplc the column
material
or the stationary phase has hydrophobic
alkyl
groups now it can form hydrophobic bond
with nonpolar or hydrophobic and nylon
so obviously
in this case when we inject the sample
the particular samples which are
hydrophobic in nature or highly
non-polar
they would be retained in the column and
their retention time would increase
whereas the polar substances
would be eluted first so overall we have
seen that
hplc can function in two different
regimes
reverse phase or in normal phase
and the column materials can be
different in these two different
operational regime
ultimately the separated annihilates
would enter the detection system
the detector the detector works
via pier lambert law there would be a
led light which passed through a filter
and ultimately it passes through the
sample
the absorbance value is detected
and this detector is generally a ccd
camera or photo multiplier tube
ultimately from the absorbance the
sample concentration
and purity can be monitored or can be
calculated
and ultimately the sample would flow
through these
tubes and while it is flowing through
this detector
the light from the led can pass through
the sample and
provide us the necessary information
about that particular annihilate and
that particular
information is converted to a digital
signal
which is displayed in the monitor so in
the monitor
absorbance versus retention time graph
is plotted and it plots the chromatogram
here
the number of peak in this chromatogram
depicts how many
annihilate molecules are there also with
the help of retention time we would
understand the sequence of illusion of
these particular
annihilate molecules so let us quickly
review
the advantage and disadvantage of this
hplc system
coming to the advantage part hplc have
very high resolving power because it
used high pressure and very small
particle size of the bead which increase
the surface area and enhance the
separation procedure
the speed of separation is unprecedented
and it is very much reproducible so it
can be used under
laboratory conditions or in industrial
settings
the automated sampler makes it easy to
use
and it can be adapted for
industrial purposes and high throughput
works then disadvantage includes it
could be
expensive because the hplc setup
is expensive at the first run but it is
very efficient i would say
in summary we have looked at working
principle of hplc
advantages versus disadvantages of hplc
and we also had a quick idea that how
the hplc data is analyzed how the
chromatogram looked like
which gave us an overall understanding
of this procedure
so i hope you enjoyed this video if you
like this video give it a quick thumbs
up
don't forget to like share and subscribe
and you can join
my courses in an academy using my code
ap 10 you can get a
10 discount on my courses thank you guys
thanks for listening
and do let me know in the comment how
you like my videos thank you